oh let's roll game on so this is a
little bit slower I can't be too
reckless with throwing away pieces in
this tournament so let's try something a
bit more solid yes that's a good way to
start off a tournament a quick resigner
these are 2-minute ones lyrica 2010 I'm
still gonna go for this but I'm gonna
try to be a bit more precise let's roll
here a six Queen c7 fishing pole and if
there's terms you are not familiar with
in the chat feel free to ask others I
should have just grabbed that pun I
guess I could still get it yeah this
pond is going down it's hit three times
I could work myself into a little bit of
a pin but I should be able to defend
without much of a problem I really don't
want to play Bishop here because of a
knight move here doubled pawns but he is
an extra let's get developed they're
getting that pond back but I could
finish my development now and actually
maybe I should have played that but it's
okay I want to get that Knight now but
maybe not there could be tension between
the Queen's but I get this at the end of
it okay a shattered structure I get no I
thought rook takes would be best if Rick
here I get another pawn now it's a case
of what well let me do this the rook is
a bit out of play let's trade rooks I'm
threatening me and okay let's get my
King involved I'll be accurate here
let's get this rip doing something and
if it takes I'm gonna capture it to my
King I want to keep pressure on that C
pawn that's the main reason those guys
are split rook c3 this ends up netting
upon active versus passive rook
sometimes this is worth upon advantage
outside passed pawns very valuable and I
need to do something else here and let's
come up here
Oh outside pass pawn
right here and these three these four
could stop these guys so eventually the
King has to run to the corner and then I
and then I make progress so I just kind
of danced back and forth here for a
little bit and eventually my opponent
runs out of moves I could do this no one
now push I'd capture in this direction
we pawn here again basically just
shuffling back and forth and then I make
inroads into the position they're out of
moves now and the King has to start
going here let me do that I guess oh
wait you know what I could do
King up
it's not gonna be stalemate this is
gonna work
actually I ran the calculations it
should be working here King here and
then if there's a take here and then I
take and then there is that pond that
could be moving but my pond strikes
first with me so a little bit of
calculation back to tournament
eight points is in first six six there's
not a lot of games you get in for these
two-minute ones time control efore and
what a quick resigner I'm right back up
there now 25 minutes left all right
double the points more Sicilian why not
its aggressive here and you gotta go for
the quick wins in these war zones a 6mm
the anti fishing pole to my opponent no
I was gonna be doing that they being
sneaky pawn push is no good I could take
with the Queen to a5 move to follow
Knight takes pawn is back on I want to
be cautious about giving up my dark
square Bishop actually because of what
because of these
dark squares maybe there could be a
Bishop d6 and I can't castle in some
variation okay no my bishop actually has
to back up oh okay
it's the bishop definitely has to back
up and now if this then what will my
opponent have I'm gonna throw in a check
see how its defended the Queen Bishop
block maybe can maybe pile up on that
night right here or something although I
like this structure I don't know if I
want to push here not unless it's going
to gain material and I think I'm
actually gaining material with this move
right here important move right there if
I took the pawn recaptures and I don't
have this move in successfully so I have
some shelter here in case there's an
eventual rook coming down on this e-file
and I could back up some like if the
bishop wasn't here there would be this
b4 move but not in this case it's pinned
and there is no breaking the pen there
is no b4 move in other words okay let's
take and oh this is a very annoying
bishop right here watching over a four
or a four how'd I get e4 out of that one
okay I'm gonna do this because I want to
get this rook working if I played here
there was a bishop check and then my
rooks aren't connected okay let's play
here Bishop here next
even if I'm dropping upon I want to do
that okay let's get here
and there's not enough pieces around to
really get at my king so time is not an
issue either at this point what else
Bishop takes Bishop no okay well I make
a slightly defensive move right here and
I guess another one would be the bishop
coming here what piece is causing me the
most problems this bishop actually both
bishops their pain so here's the plan
get my Bishop to e7 they don't have any
time that's not gonna actually happen
come here and I'll defend that pawn like
this so I'm playing on three ranks but
the three ranks that I'm playing on are
you know I'm playing at up a piece so
this is okay they don't have any time
and I can block here next finally smoke
is cleared but there is no no time for
white okay back to tournament 1616 and
12 and a 10
all right there is 20 minutes and change
remaining in this one okay efore Sheldon
Cooper this is a guy that I should have
beat me I think in the 123 18 he's right
up there with 14 points so we're having
to drag in here dragon what Bishop d7
rook c8 line okay and I don't know where
to go here let's try hmm right here I
guess and let's try this
okay now he's got to go and my knight
wants to be a defender
I need to get rid of that um Bishop I
think I run the risk of getting trapped
here oh man that's a brutal move oh I am
a dead man or am i oh man what a sad
move to have to make my bishop I needed
to come over here to negate that bishop
this is so bad right here there's got to
be something I got a sack upon just to
have my rooks Guard stuff laterally no
it's ready to be deflected Oh my knight
is dead I'm a dead man I don't have any
defense my dark squares are so weak
right now oh man this is brutal
I'm so beat right here
way be clean right here is good too
probably oh man
yupper very good I'm a dead man oh man I
am dead what can you do take here and
hope for the best
is this somehow what why did they
miscalculate there they were supposed to
take my rook in the corner that's still
working though no wait a second I might
have a defense my bishop is here to
watch the night do I have a defense
ah
I'm gonna try this and then defend whoa
can I actually come back from this my
Knights gonna block whoa whoa whoa whoa
dark squares dark squares everywhere my
knight is a good defender against the
Queen checks can I get this can I get
this can I get it can I get it can I get
it um this is good I have a connect to
pass pawn pawn push oh well that was
missed probably Queen to f6 and I think
I have everything glued together clock
is coming back oh but there's that move
I'm on the Queen they're gonna take
Forks otherwise there's a fork all the
Queen's are off tricky Knight I need a
tricky Knight
give me a pawn my Knights dead it's
gonna be dead come on you could get this
maybe I can't have upon check it's gonna
be pinned oh it's dead it's dead it's
dead it's dead can I get this pawn get
the rook ah no time no time no time
Oh me me me I'm dead meat oh man Oh
Queen takes that pond I was in a pen
what a roller coaster ride that one was
ah man what a roller coaster I was beat
without a doubt and then I had a glimmer
of hope or two and then I was beat again
and then I lost huh oh that took the
wind right out of me
that took the confetti right out of me
right there
me me I'm dead me ah man took the wind
right out of me
you can do it you could do this still
don't you dare start thinking about
letting uh giving up set in here no okay
let's stop Bishop g5 oh man bishop dese
bishop right here
tricky discoveries opposite the Queen
should be scared I got the seafloor
square and maybe some other squares I
want to trade Queens because then I
won't get mated maybe let's trade Queens
please I want to lock down on the light
squares here light square control here
we go Oh quick resigner come on they
forgot the night goes back oh come on
this is resigned time resigned time oh
man just castle anything kill a Bishop
rook activity pigs on the second pigs
one pig ready to be on the second one
pig
looking for another one in a different
way
discovered attack discover check pigs
pigs pigs on the second Oh to take that
pond whenever I want looking for makin
one ah
the king is weaseling away he's gonna
run away why did I let him run away oh
man this is so wrong why am i allowing
this nonsense
this is nonsense Oh watch out for the
tricky pots or mates who knows what I'm
talking about that's what I just had a
flashback of okay back to Chairman 24 oh
that loss is killing me
I'm in ninth 13 minutes and change here
yes a quick resigner 30 42 is top I have
30 13 and change Patricia
double the points Patricia 2037
Patricia's up there 37 points okay let's
let's play a little bit more accurate
that was a terrible dragon uh terrible
Sicilian that I played that that dark
squared Bishop gave me a beating and a
half ah
let's go oh this is gonna be brutal
isn't it just trade nights so I'd have
to worry about e6 anymore okay let's do
that
take my night I'm okay with uh I'm gonna
try this direction - although Queen here
I'm around here - block take my knife
double the pawns a lot my bishop - come
out here double pawns are very good yes
okay my King gets to run a little bit
scared let's do this everything should
be quite all right
bishop here bishop what this can't be
right no way
there's no way that that could be right
or can it okay now there's mates if the
rook tries to get from us excited about
this file here and I'm just gonna take
with my king a lot have to cuz I have to
watch out for my bishop whoa
what's happening with that move what
okay I'm gonna take like this ah I got
them back ranked mates or do i I still
have it back ranked mates stop before
I'm up a clear to pieces now just make
sure my clean is there I'm gonna give it
back or am I I just dropped okay let me
it just can't be easy can it huh I want
to get out of this pin I'm giving a
piece back but okay let's get out of
this pin now I'm finally gonna be able
to get out of it okay not the best
technique not at all I have three pawns
versus a bishop let's take this one and
then run my H pawn can I get that H pawn
going this is so bad this technique is
so bad let's keep going upon let's get
this guy with the check and then grab
this guy and then get going a bit more
I'm not even sure what that move is
doing oh I'm in trouble my bishop needs
to be somewhere else right here I just
want a sack
get in position over here I'm giving up
that pun Oh is this scary or what I'm
gonna get maded and scream oh I'm close
to getting made and I'm close to getting
mated nah
what do I do what's the one accurate
move can I make one accurate move here
how about that
I work in no I'm dropping my Brooke
check oh wait did I calculate this I
might have I didn't that's a lie
oh man can I get this can I get this I'm
Mike still gonna get it oh I still might
have it barely barely have it barely oh
I just have the squares covered just in
the nick of time right here right here
oh just barely just barely the pond has
to move now Wow and the king could go to
this square next barely run for the
hills pond wow that got way too close
where are the quick wins not the quick
resign errs what about the games where I
actually have to play and when they are
nowhere to be found and defense defense
I was on right there okay open Sicilian
accelerated queenside expansion here
alright let's take this and pile up on
this e six pawn may be Queen coming out
to g4 okay I should have played a four
first I think okay well I want to get
rid of this Knight and then and then
what well now let's do this I guess very
difficult to break down that pawn rook
here and actually excuse me Bishop right
here I think is a good thing and this is
gonna take ages to win oh this is gonna
take forever to win okay well here is
the plan the plan is to get I can't even
get in g5 successfully
maybe we'll trade Queens can we just
trade Queens I think I might have a
better chance of winning if the Queens
are off okay
isn't that coming close to being trapped
whoa hang on here the Queen is
definitely going astray what is she
thinking about she is now sectioned off
to that Kings side now I might want to
play this and then target this pond so
we're about even with time I better be
in a position to support this guy and
there's a bad stuff that can happen real
quick on h4 I should probably play King
to g2 and now is a good time this is
tough I need to guard over here my
second rank needs definitely be
protected all right let's do this
and Queen trade
let's try Queen trade oh man struggling
here definitely struggling ok the
Queen's are off
ok so feeling a little bit safer at
least a little more safe let's get this
guy now I've rook activity and and I
kill it the pun watch over it pig one
Pig right here and my opponents ready to
undermine this structure so I want to be
prepared to recap with my rip right here
King right here and what next
I wonder if King up to h5 and then g4 g
5 if H 6 as the flight square let's try
that actually there might be something
to it okay there might I might also be
getting mated fortunately my bishop is
here oh this is a bad this is a bad
position
no rook to c4 would have been really
good the bishops dead and then there'd
be a mate right there against my king Oh
oh look out that got a little scary
right there so I'm sneaking in with my
King pawn push and then King here King
position I look up and over mates and a
few I think they're down on time 60s
somebody has 85 blunder oh four is up
there nine wins five minutes and change
can I get a top three even these guys
can still catch me these four I have any
one of anybody on the top the top ten
right now could still win it this guy's
negative twenty is he gonna move a non
mover he's got negative twenty ah - non
mover how many points would I get I'd
get about ten ten points let me do the
math I get ten I'd be at seventy right
oh they moved okay they are playing no
they resigned the quick resigner 69 85
69 66 65 let's go five minutes and
change here we go let's roll here what
happened just then did I just get paired
up and I closed out accidentally no okay
can I get a win here let's try this okay
all right let's try this Bishop b5 line
and okay mm-hmm I might work against
this structure right here
somehow the Queen's could come off if
pawn takes then there'd be double
isolated pawns
pawn takes I take the night and then
recapture I think what are they gonna do
let's go Castle Queen e2 maybe actually
I want to work on this I mean here and
night here c4 is what I want can I get
that in there might be a c4 move that's
good
I'm gonna have to see about that night
here c4 is where I want to be b3 as well
I'm ready to I'm doing these sorts of
moves to lock
this LightSquared bishop but i'm playing
like it's a longer game like i'm not
playing in a way where I could try and
win quick but I think it's still like a
good strategy to be applying in like a
more serious tournament so I could
actually do this if there's a bishop
takes after this this I take with my
queen and now this bishop is not going
to be able to have any fun for the
remainder of the game as long as I'm
accurate with my moves Bishop d2 this
may look familiar if those of you have
seen the five minute fanatics tournament
that I posted to the YouTube channel
this was the last game in that group of
four did the Queen and from here I think
I pushed the night away and now this
pond this pond and well there's nothing
going on now I want to avoid that
exchange or maybe Bishop to a5 would
have been good actually I'm gonna try
that Bishop to a5 and now what you have
to get rid of that Bishop before you can
really do anything it's come here my
knight once you get to e4 my knight on
f3 is good oh there's tactics are their
tactics okay let's come back here 94 to
d6 I have a great local majority like a
significant local majority over here why
did I allow that I shouldn't allowed
that Knight f6 has got to be brutal
though right let's try this first
there's got to be mates I won't
I need a rook lifts I'm also watching
over the pawn with that I'm gonna ah I
meant to do rook lifts okay f6 is still
really strong if that Knight is taken
there's gonna be bad things happening
really really bad things I say I should
have played here because Knight oh they
result and oh they're down on time 89
105 89 wait if I get one more win I'll
have a lead
one more win there's not gonna be any
time my opponent could always let the
time tick no they didn't 109 I got 109 I
got 109
I'm in a lead I'm in the lead right here
109 105 Park if that guy wins that's in
second though he's gonna get it he
doubled the points what do we have what
do we have what do we have f7 can I get
F seven real quick they could always
just let their time burn though and I
can't win and my bishop has to run away
scared because I didn't play d3 in time
okay can I get it back are they to take
out for something no okay ah was that
guy gonna win he's probably winning his
game right now come on do I have to go
for a cheap win matin one threat there's
only a minute five left in the
tournament approximately let's go one
minute less than a minute they're just
gonna let the clock tick no they're not
they're not let's take care get on east
600 it's close to me give me the night
give me the night give me the night take
that night take the night and then queen
h5 something take the night oh the king
is running away don't run away this way
don't do that rook here sac on b5
where's the king gonna go okay I want to
get to this square there's only 28
seconds let's go here mm-hmm did I get
this there's gonna be a check on a five
and I have to go back to block or not
wait is there gonna be a check here
maybe I can block with my bishop it's
close to me ten seconds just move mate
mate mate mate mate mate mate what do we
got first yes
Oh first please confetti gimme it I'm
gonna take it oh not without some help
though 109 105 103 oh man barely barely
good games oh all right